idement.
[Silence]
woman.
Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Allah. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells
us in some of the closing verses in Alab
he tells us that which translates to and
behold
the parables and the analogies that we
present to the people which are only
going to be understood
by the knowledgeable.
And he says subhanahu wa ta'ala in the
closing verses of
indeed
in the creation of the heavens and the
earth
and the changing the intermittent
changing between and the cycling between
day and night is
enough evidence and there are signs
for the people or the men of
understanding,
the men of true understanding.
These verses,
what do they contain? What is common
between these two verses? What do they
share in their meaning?
They share in their meaning presenting
us
with perspective.
And this is the issue we'd to
discuss this evening. The issue of
perspective.
If a person is standing
in the hereafter
and looking back at the dunya,
who would they view from that vantage
point to be the people of knowledge and
the people of understanding? Would they
from the hereafter looking through the
lens of the hereafter
standing on the day of judgment in front
of Allah
looking back at the dunya that we are in
right now today?
Who would we consider from that vantage
point to be the men of understanding?
Who would we consider to be the people
of knowledge? Who would we consider to
be the fortunate?
Who would we consider to be the truly
impoverished and poor? Who would we
consider to be wealthy? From that
vantage point, from that place.
When we look at the dunya and we are
here in this dunya,
we have different understandings
of who the people of knowledge are. Who
the men of understanding are, who we
consider to be wealthy, who we consider
to be poor, who we consider to be
fortunate, who we consider to be
unfortunate
in the dunya. But in the hereafter
that perspective is going to change
and the true people of understanding and
knowledge and wealth will
become apparent to us from that place at
that time.
You notice here how Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala in the Quran he gives us
definitions.
He gives us definitions of the people of
wealth,
the people of knowledge, the people of
understanding.
He gives us in the Quran definitions
for the losers. Who is a loser? Who is a
person who is a winner?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala gives us
definitions that are contrary to what
our culture or our time and place
dictate.
We consider the wealthy to be someone
who has a lot of money. We consider a
poor person to be someone who doesn't.
We consider a fortunate person to be
someone who is healthy and strong and
someone who has all of his children and
a person who is free of misery and
sadness and hardship.
And we consider a person who is
unfortunate
to be a person who has hardship in his
life. We consider the people of
knowledge and the intellectuals amongst
us to be the people with the most
degrees and the most plaques on their
walls.
And we consider the winners to be the
most accomplished in this world.
However,
even us, if we were to stand on the
landscape of the hereafter and think
back to the dunya and look at those same
people today and consider who of them we
view as wealthy or poor, it would change
drastically.
When we look at the definitions given to
us in the Quran, they are given to us
from the perspective
of the hereafter.
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
a person of knowledge, he is speaking
about the people of knowledge in the
hereafter.
those who were given knowledge of the
Quran and Sunnah and were granted
the
success by Allah to implement that
knowledge in their life. Those are the
people of understanding.
Those who say
those are the men of intellect. Those
are the intellectuals. Even if they
don't know how to write or read, those
are the intellectuals.
Because all of this busy work in the
hereafter,
we will shed it when we die.
We will shed everything that will not be
of immediate consequence to our souls in
the hereafter.
I want to share a story with you and
this is a very interesting story and I
want you when you hear this story
know that this is something that
absolutely happened.
This is something
that occurred.
And I want you to think when you hear
this story about your immediate reaction
to it. What do you consider this story
to be?
I want you to think about that when
listening to it.
Many of us, most of us have heard of the
great Khalifa Omarbiz
Abd Aziz was only the Khalifa for a
couple of years. But he came at a time
when oppression had spread and
corruption had made its way into the
Muslima
and government
where murder and fitna had become
commonplace
and within those couple of years Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala restored the balance
and the justice this to the land and
filled it with light
as it had previously been filled with
darkness just in those two years with
Omar Abd Aziz. He was a scholar. He grew
up a prince. He was later the Khalifa of
the Muslim
and he restored the Quran and Sunnah and
he restored the balance and the legacy
of the prophet Muhammad sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam and his successors.
Just in a couple of years
because of his knowledge and his
dedication and sincerity,
Omarb Abd Aziz is considered
so virtuous
amongst the Muslims and the scholars
specifically
that they refer to him as the fifth
Khalifa of the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. The prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam had four four successors.
However, even though Omarb Abd Aziz came
so far after and even though he was not
a companion and even though he
was came up in a time that was a
rather shady time in the history of
Islamic government.
However, his sil and his biography
and his ethic was so superb
that it belongs on the shelf on the same
shelf as the of the companions the four
Abu Bakr and
Ali
Omar Abd we've heard of him many of us
have.
However, a lot of us haven't heard of
where this man came from. What kind of
environment did he grow up in? He was
once a boy, a young child,
and he grew up in a particular
environment that set him on the course
and trajectory that he later ended up
on.
one of the
stories that kind of highlights this
environment that he grew up in. Even
though he was a prince and he grew up
extremely wealthy, he grew up so wealthy
that he never had to really use money.
That's how wealthy he grew up. You know
when a person becomes so wealthy that
they don't even use money anymore. This
kind of wealth that he grew up around
and his father
sent him
to
a scholar of hadith and linguistics
named
one of the great narrators of hadith of
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam. a
muhadith and major scholar of his time.
He sent him to
teach him etiquets and knowledge.
And this is what people aspired to back
then. The Muslims, they would send their
children not to boarding school, not to
private schools, not to go. They would
send them to the most knowledgeable of
scholars of Islam so that they would
grow up under the watching eye of the
greatest scholars of Islam.
And so one of his first teachers was
Salahban.
One of the first things that he told
Omar Abd Aziz that he was responsible
for was coming to every salah in J
and he was never to be late. What is
late?
late is considered walking in the masid
or joining
after the imam has already said Allahbar
you come in at that moment you're
already late
and so one day he noticed that
came in
after the imam had make that made that
initial
so he missed
the initial. He missed it.
He didn't miss the first.
He missed
the first.
Do any of us consider that? It's like
not a big deal at all. What's the
problem?
in case noticed this and he asked him
after why were you late?
I saw you missed the first technique of
why.
He said
that
he said I was having my hair braided. As
we mentioned before in the time of the
companions, the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam their and the Arab culture at
that time long hair was the norm. It was
very unusual to see a man with short
hair.
And the way they would keep their hair
is it would be long and they would braid
it in big braids and then wear their
imama over it. Well, this is a process.
This takes time. If you shower and take
your braids out, it takes time for it to
be braided again. And so he had a
servant that was braiding his hair. And
it took a little longer than he
expected. And because of that, he missed
the first tech. So he wasn't playing
around. He wasn't being negligent.
And soban
said, "I'm going to tell your father
about this." And he sent a message to
his father immediately because
was in Medina. He sent a message to his
father immediately. your son missed
and he claims it's because he was having
his hair braided. If you received that
message about your son or your daughter,
think about it. You got a complaint from
your child's teacher that they missed
because they were having their hair
braid. What would your reaction be?
Most of us, what would we think about
that, right? Most of us.
However, what was his father's reaction?
He sent a message back to his son. I
will not speak to you again until you
shave your head.
And he had his head shaved
so as to learn the lesson
that this and this they are not on the
same level.
This is not an excuse for this. Now,
your first reaction, your immediate
reaction to that story. This is what we
want to talk about tonight.
What was your immediate reaction to that
story?
In your heart of hearts, you don't have
to tell me, but a lot of us would kind
of look at this and say, you know,
that's that's a little bit extreme.
In your heart of hearts, you might think
that's a little bit extreme. That's a
little bit overboard,
right?
However,
this issue of extreme and moderate,
this is an issue of perspective.
It's not an issue of this is something
which is unacceptable or this is
something which is inappropriate. It's
an issue it's an issue of perspective.
If your reaction to that is that this is
a little bit extreme,
tell me what if your child
was in swimming
and they shaved their head so that they
could swim in the swim team swim faster.
Is your reaction to that that that is
extreme? Is it extreme?
That's normal for that sport. What about
if your child had lice? He shaved his
head because he had lice and he can't go
back to school as long as he has this
lice. Had to shave his head. What about
if it was the the custom of our culture
that boys shave their head? Would it be
extreme? No. These things aren't
extreme. So, it's not that the issue
itself is extreme. It's an issue of
perspective.
That act itself is not extreme. It's
just what are your priorities?
If your priorities are the hereafter,
that is absolutely part for the course.
Then you would understand stories of
companions
like
one of the companions of Ibas
who used to spank his son if he would
make salah without making the dua at the
very end.
seeking refuge in Allah from four
things. I seek refuge in you, oh Allah,
from the fitna of al- and the fitna of
the the punishment of the grave. Four
things. A well-known hadith. This is not
obligatory.
It's highly encouraged. He used to spank
his son and command him to do the salah
over. Make the entire salah over because
you missed it. Other companions
and would spank their children for
making grammatical mistakes
when narrating the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam's narrations or reciting the
Quran or speaking classical Arabic. They
would spank their children for making
grammatical mistakes. Why is that
extreme?
What if your child burned your house
down? Would you spank them?
What if they were playing with matches?
What if they took a baseball bat and
broke your windshield just for fun?
Would you spank them? The act itself
is not extreme. It's an issue of
priorities.
So when you read about
Omarb Abd Aziz,
this isn't just some fantasy
story about how a man just came out of
nowhere from nothing and he was so great
and turned into the Khalifa of Muhammad
Sall.ai wasam even though he came
several decades
over half a century after him. It was
because he was raised by men.
Men who had priorities
and they instilled those priorities into
their children and they taught them what
was expected of them and what would not
be tolerated
and those children grew up to be men
and so on it goes.
However, when we become softened by the
dunya, when our priorities change and
our perspectives change and we start to
give definitions
to things mentioned in the Quran and
Sunnah with other than the definitions
of Allah and his messenger, this is
where we reach and arrive at the
junction we find ourselves today.
[Silence]
We ask Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
teach us that which will benefit us and
to benefit us from that which he teaches
us.
Alhamdulillah.